in our panel early tonight ben dominic
publisher of the federalist
katie pavlich news editor at
townhall.com and jonathan swann national
political reporter for axios
jonathan you broke this story about the
pipeline
nordstrom 2 and the sanctions being
waived by the biden administration
i think rich laid it out there at the
top of the show but the importance of
this
and what it means well
it's hugely important um it's vladimir
putin
basically maintaining strategic leverage
in europe
it's a direct pipeline between russia
and germany
it cuts out ukraine completely uh
harming
the ukrainians and they're very worried
about this and
really what what this decision which
their planned
amounts to is the united states deciding
that it's more
important to keep the germans happy and
to preserve that relationship with
germany
than it is to do everything in their
power to stop the completion of this
pipeline
um and it also raises a really bizarre
situation
this is going to be laid out in a report
that they're mandated to give to
congress every
90 days we're going to see a situation
where the admit biden administration
says
okay and your correspondent laid this
out we're sanctioning you know a handful
of russian
ships but we are not sanctioning in fact
we're waving
uh the company that runs the pipeline
and one of putin's cronies who's the ceo
of that company so
it just creates extreme cognitive
dissonance
and it's not a really a coherent policy
yeah
it's very strange the the sanctioning
that they're talking about the smaller
entities and not the big company
the other thing i point out is that the
administration says that they really
want to improve the relationship with
germany
uh from what it was with the trump
administration it was the obama
administration that had to tell publicly
in 2015 that the nsa was
listening to merkel's phone calls cell
phone calls
and said that that damaged the
relationship with germany jonathan
just the other thing to this does the
administration acknowledge that they are
softer on russia
than the trump administration no
of course they would never acknowledge
that but uh
there's several things that they've done
already which
uh which you know amount to that in many
people's view
uh certainly in republicans view that
number one they were very quick to renew
the arms control treaty with russia uh
new stuff they did that immediately
and uh and now on on nordstream 2
they're just not going as far as
as many republicans want them to go and
just there's another
piece of context that's really important
to remember here which is
construction on this pipeline actually
halted
under the trump administration it had
basically come to a standstill
and it resumed after biden took office
it's true the pipeline is almost
completed about 95
complete but the fact is they're not
doing whatever they can
despite promising that they would to
stop this final
stretch of the pipeline yeah ben i mean
i would add to
the policies also oil production
which uh obviously kept oil prices very
low and hurt russia
the fact that iran was um the
administration the trump administration
had their
kind of boot on the neck of iran an ally
of russia
there's a list of them uh differences
between the administrations
well i think the phrase that jonathan
used cognitive dissonance is a good
summation of the biden foreign policy to
this point
and look when you look at the situation
in the middle east everything should be
viewed through the lens of the
differences between these
administrations as it relates to iran
iran really wants to get that 2015 magic
back
when you had the jcpoa when you had you
know their proxies performing very well
in syria and lebanon and the like
and they want to get back to that point
and they feel like they have an
opportunity which is
really i think the lens we have to look
at what's going on with hamas
through that moment they want to seize a
moment with an administration that
doesn't have a very close relationship
with israel
that has you know previously been open
to these kinds of deals with them in the
past
they've been reeling after four years of
the trump administration
as you say having the boot on the neck
of the iranians
along with israel you know taking the
numerous steps that really hurt them
and now they're trying to seize this
opportunity in the early days of this
administration i hope that there are
enough
people involved in this in this
administration who disagree with that
who can push back against it yeah katie
back to russia republican lawmakers
already
sounding these notes saying it's pretty
ironic
that it is this administration that as a
campaign
spent a lot of time going after
president trump
for russia connections or somehow being
easy on russia for four years
that that is seem to ease up uh take a
listen to this compilation
do you believe the president right now
has been an agent of the russians
yes i i think there's more evidence yes
and i i think all the arrows point in
that direction i haven't seen a single
piece of evidence that he's not
not only has he failed to sanction or
impose any kind of consequences on
russia
for this egregious violation of
international law donald trump has
continued his embarrassing campaign
of deference and debasing himself before
vladimir putin
his entire presidency has been a gift to
putin
for all the talk about president trump
and russia no one was tougher on russia
than president trump
and the world knows the world knows that
biden is weak
thoughts on that katie
well it just proves that democrats and
then candidate joe biden now president
joe biden was all talk when it came to
talking tough on russia and now the
actions that are following
aren't tough like they were under the
trump administration president trump was
always asked to
publicly condemn vladimir putin while
behind closed doors and publicly they
were issuing sanctions they were going
after their energy resources
and this is not just about one decision
on a pipeline this is a major
geopolitical win for vladimir putin for
russia and it also brings up big
questions about the role of nato
when they are going to allow russia to
have
serious control over a massive energy
source
and of course the economic benefits that
come with that and then domestically
with the backdrop here politically you
have the same white house saying that
they are open to canceling
future pipelines in the united states
they just canceled the keystone pipeline
and had this awful gas shortage with the
hack of the colonial pipeline and so
when you look at
the administration approving
controversial and damaging
pipelines overseas for russia and giving
them a geopolitical win
while canceling or cancelling pipelines
here and also saying in the future we're
not going to necessarily stop
uh the con or start or approve the
construction of future pipelines for our
own
national security reasons that's a that
does not
bode well and it does not reconcile
itself well for the biden
foreign or domestic policy on energy
last thing quickly jonathan that's still
moving forward with this meeting with
putin
yeah i mean i don't know what the agenda
is actually
uh but yes they want to
uh he wants to sit down with uh putin
there's a lot of things to talk about
and
uh one thing that they've stressed
repeatedly is the climate
issue which uh you know that america is
i think it's something like 15
of global emissions so if they are going
to tackle this globally they're going to
need
china and russia to agree to stringent
standards
uh pretty difficult when i think it was
john mccain who said that uh
russia is a gas station with an army or
a country
i can't remember the exact phrase but
you know the idea that putin is going to
become
an enlightened climate uh activist is
something that i'm you know curious to
see well jonathan nice scoop today
panel we'll see you later on the show
thank you